um probably this woman I met NLB or
knows in PB at the Buffalo Exchange
there she came up to me she was like
your makeup is so pretty you're so
pretty like let me follow your Instagram
so I gave her my Instagram we shopped
for a little while and then her
boyfriend came up
and he like gave really bad vibes and
like her like physical demeanor like
changed I could tell like he was like
abusive probably
and so I walked away because like her
physical demeanor like dropped and I was
like okay this guy's kind of scary and I
walked away a couple feet and then I
heard him like
verbally like abusing her like she
didn't want to hang out with you you're
so annoying this is what I deal with on
a daily basis see how she walked away
like as soon as she could this was like
five years ago and I literally like
still think about it and like get really
sad because
she unfollowed me on Instagram because
he obviously made hers because like as
soon as I
heard that I walked up to him and I said
excuse me like I can hear you you're
being really like a dick to your
girlfriend right now and he was like
what are you talking about and I was
like she was being really kind to me we
had a really good time I don't
appreciate that you were saying that I
was annoyed by her and that I didn't
want to talk to her because it's not
true that's not how I felt like if he's
doing that in public what is he doing
when he's not in public as soon as I
left the store he had definitely made
her unfollow me because the notification
was gone and I haven't forgotten about
that because I just I worry I like think
about her a lot
and I just hope she got out of that
relationship
makes me sad
so there was this guy that was outside
of this restaurant and he was unhoused
he's like hey
um can I have some change and he had
like a little cup I had a couple of like
more dollars than I usually have and
like I just gave him like 20 bucks and
he would like smiled so big I just could
see and feel the Gratitude from him
um and he basically was just like my
name's Joe and he repeated that multiple
times and like my name's Joe and I was
like
Joe so I always remember him because
when he was just like my name's Joe just
like in that moment he just seemed like
a person that was like
I just want
another being to kind of recognize me
and remember
like who I like am or was or whatever
um so I remember always remember Joe and
I said I'm saying say hi to him in my
head I'm like I hope you're having a
good day Joe uh Hawaiian Jesus
yeah all right so I'm living in Wahoo
for a little bit right
and going to work every day I saw him it
was the most majestic lean
shirtless and he had a weird swag and he
looked like a Hawaiian like a Polynesian
Jesus
I saw him every morning for like one
year and I always wanted it always
walking around this one Cemetery one day
I just went hey man I'm gonna go try to
talk to this if I have to man because I
don't know who he is he looks just I
need to take a picture of him and just
to see who he is what he is and why he's
always walking at this certain time and
he's like going towards this like
Cemetery Little Cemetery so I parked and
try to go the day I wanted to so saw him
every day but the day I actually wanted
to see him
he never did he was never there and
every day after that I never saw him
again
so I don't know who he was the strange
I'll never meet but he was beautiful
so one time a couple of years ago I took
a trip up to Ireland I saw a
construction worker that had some like
really interesting pants that had like
external pockets and I just asked them
you know blithely like oh hey those are
some interesting pants uh with the with
the little interesting pockets and this
guy goes to proceed to tell him talk to
me for like a good solid three minutes
about his pants and about his work the
problem was his Irish accent was so
thick I couldn't discern a single word
all I could tell was that he was really
excited to tell me and all I could say
response was oh that's really cool
cheers and then walk away
but I really appreciate that he was just
so open just so friendly and I don't
know I maybe maybe I made his day is
just like some American wanted to know
about his pants for some reason so I
still remember that and it still reminds
me that Ireland is a magical place where
people are willing to talk to you about
their pants if you ask them
uh I met a guy
guy who walked up to us with a dog and
then he came to us and said hey do you
want to trade your girl for my dog
because
um he wants to have a nice girl as her
yeah I kept the girl at the end he could
have had the dog
one time a stranger told me
that I'm I'm closer to a million dollars
than I thought and he told me I'm only
one thought away from a million dollars
and that that changed my life how long
ago was this
it was about
five years ago now
and are you do you feel like you're
closer to a million dollars
I'm one thought closer to a million
dollars
um I was in high
with all my books and stuff after school
there was like an older gentleman
probably in his 70s and he looked at me
and he just said hey Michelle
and I was like
what the heck I had no idea who he was
um but he at the end of the conversation
was like did you wonder how I knew your
name and I was like yeah I did actually
have I met you before and he was like no
your name is just written on the side of
your book and I was like
but I always think about that because I
was so young and
it's a classic example of like
not realizing when you're young how
obvious some things are right well I
don't remember her name because she's a
stranger she probably told me briefly
um I had just got enough work sometimes
I work in the Parks during the summer as
a park ranger so it's late and we're
gonna try to head up to Grinnell Glacier
by the time it got dark so we're heading
out at three in the afternoon this was
probably not wise on a lot of levels and
we were about halfway up and we came
around the corner thank you
and there was a young woman sitting on a
rock
with just tennis shoes and a plastic
water bottle not a proper pack pack or
anything
and we asked her like where's your
people what are you doing and she said
oh they went up ahead the trail I'm sure
they'll be back I said you want to hike
with us you shouldn't be sitting here
alone do you have any bear spray she
said no she said well it's getting dark
like you should walk with us you're
almost there and she didn't have enough
water or anything so she walked with us
and the minute she started to walk I
could see that she had a
a disability her gait was off her leg
slightly dragged and so we started to
talk and she was telling me about how
she was here with a group of friends
working but they had left her behind on
the trail
to go up ahead to the glacier because
she was too slow
and so I was like well you shouldn't
hike by yourself come with us and we got
up to the glacier and she was so happy
that she made it and we turned around
and go back and it took a really long
time because her walking was unsteady
and she kept saying I'm sure my friends
will be waiting for me I'm sure they'll
be waiting for me and um
to Trail One Way in one way out I don't
know where they were but we did not pass
her friends and it's getting darker and
darker and darker we get to the parking
lot
where her friends
should have been parked and their car
was not there
and I could just see her
uh it was getting it was dark by this
time and there's no cell service by the
way there's no internet so
I could tell she was pretty shaken that
they weren't there and I'm like no
worries just come back to my cabin you
can sleep with us so I took her back to
the cabin with us we had dinner and she
slept at the house
and the next morning I get up and I
drive her back to
her cabin I'm trying to withhold
judgment on the fact that her friends
had abandoned her
to the Bears in the dark with no water
and bear sprays but anyhow
I get back to I drop her off say goodbye
I get back to my own Ranger housing and
report to work to find out that her
friends had indeed reported her missing
and and the law enforcement Rangers had
been up all night doing a search and
rescue and I mean while she was sleeping
in my cabin like right behind ranger
station
I felt really bad I was like oh she was
at my house
and um so the lesson learned is um
check with your colleagues when you find
someone stranded on a trail because so I
will never forget that it's very humbled
about that experience on a lot of levels
yeah okay there you go
there was this one lady I was about 16
years old and I've just gotten off of
work and I was like sitting outside
waiting for the bus and like I had my
uniform on it and everything was like a
white shirt black pants and this lady
comes off a uh like a party bus for the
baseball game and she like comes up to
me and she like was asking like how I
was doing as if like I don't know I feel
like she felt sorry for me for some
reason and she she went to the subway
across the street bought me a sandwich
gave me a 20 gift card at Subway and
just gave me a hug and basically told me
that everything was gonna be okay which
I was fine I was just waiting for the
bus but I think she felt sorry for me in
some way but it really just goes to show
like how people can be nice and I just
honestly think it was probably the most
genuine thing that anyone's ever done
for me it's been almost 10 years so to
whoever you were thank you he's very
nice the person standing next to me we
flew in on the plane together I was
coming from Virginia and she was going
home we met what in Chicago Chicago yeah
yeah five hour Leo in Chicago and she
was sitting there and she just looked
over at me and she's she gave me a smile
and I'm like oh I smiled back for her
it's like so here we are I'm out here
for a month and she says I'll call you
and here we are she's giving me a tour
and we're strangers no more yes people
don't take the time to talk and just
smile you know we did we made that eye
contact and it's no weird stuff to say
hi hi and yeah so you know you have a
friend would you say you guys are
friends now yeah yes oh yeah we're gonna
keep in touch even though we're I'm on
Virginia and she's here in California
oh
all right so whenever you're ready who's
one stranger you still remember okay
well the answer is actually I have never
met a stranger because once I do meet
them they become a friend
it's every stranger you've met has
become your friends sure there you go
thank you
[Music]